at 23 you're going to think differently
from 33 at 33 it's likely that you're
going to think of a few people that you
said no to at 23 that were perfectly
fine and you kind of didn't because you
kept thinking I can do better and this I
can do better is eating people up MH
because it creates constant restlessness
in relationships in life in Pursuit and
then they need to go and
meditate to get calmer to be less
restless but the restlessness is this
constant pursuit of more better younger
and therefore living with the feeling
not enough I don't have enough I'm not
enough and that's the crisis that then
follows around selfworth because you
constantly want more you end up
constantly feeling not enough